Hey youtubers it's Charlie! So Game of Thrones just released a brand new preview for
Season 4 with a ton of new footage
and a lot of comments from the actors. So
just like last time I wanted to do a
breakdown of all the new things we saw.
Quick heads up though, because Game of
Thrones isn't coming back till April I'm going
to be starting a Special Countdown Video
Series in March!
I have more information about that in
the Q&A video that I'm going to do on
Wednesday.
Be sure to SUBSCRIBE to get that. But get
excited, it's going be a lot of fun. I'll be
doing a Giveaway just like I'm doing in
my Walking Dead videos right now.
For this video I'm only going to be
talking about the new footage we saw
Because there were a lot of scenes that
were repeated from that season 4 trailer.
In case you're finding me for the first time,
I'll have a link to that other Breakdown
at the end of this video.
All the things I talk about will just be
in chronological order of the order they
appeared in the HBO video.
Careful for spoilers if you don't know
anything, but Cue The Dragons,
Let's GO! In the pre-roll The Forge is
being used to melt down Ned Stark's giant
two-handed Valyrian Great Sword (ICE).
It's being made into two smaller blades.
The larger one on the left is Oathkeeper.
And the smaller one on the right is Widow's
Wail. #2 - This is the new home where
Daenerys' dragons live beneath HER new
home.
There's actually a screenshot of that building
later in this video that I'll include.
Remember that last shot of Drogon in the
video? Yeah he's big!
#3 - Joffrey plays with one of "said new
blades." (Widow's Wail)
#4 - Arya gets back something she lost at
The Crossroads.
#5 - Bronn teaches Jaime to learn to fight
with his left hand.
#6 - Brann tries to communicate with the Three-Eyed Crow.
#7 - This is the first good shot of the
new actor playing Daario (Michiel Huisman)
#8 - This is the red Viper and his lover
Ellaria Sand.
We didn't see her in the Season 4
Trailer. #9 - The Hound at The Crossroads in
the same scene
Arya was in previously. --- So this is where
we get to the actor interviews. I'm
actually going to skip
a lot of the things they say unless they
have really important clues about
what's coming,
or important details about things they
changed from the books. But continuing on!
#10 - Gwendoline Christie the actually highlights a really important thing.
That some of the actors read ahead in
the books and some do not.
She obviously did,
but a good example of someone who does
not pay attention to the books is
Peter Dinklage.
The ones that don't mostly just do it
out of concern that it will hurt their
performance for some really important
scenes, like the wedding to Sansa
or all the big action set pieces this
season.  #11 - David Benioff
actually say something really important
here, that some of the biggest scenes
come at the END of the season.
We can talk more about the timeline
in on of my future videos maybe.
#12 - Remember at the end of Season 3 Sansa did not know about the Red Wedding.
#13 - if you look at this slate it says
"Episode 6".
In the background you can see the Red
Viper, Tywin and Mace Tyrell.
He's kind of fuzzy though. They're the
people presiding over Tyrion's Trial.
This is actually pretty huge, so  we can all
adjust our timelines accordingly.
#14 - Even though Cersei and Tyrion really
hate each other,
Lena Headey and Peter Dinklage used to
share flat in Dubrovnik whenever they
were filming.
They're actually really good friends in
real life. #15 - Tyrion and Jaime spend a
lot of time together.
It's like the season of brotherly love...No,
not THAT "Twincest" kind of love...
#16 - This is the first on set interview
with Pedro Pascal
HBO has posted. He hasn't officially said a
lot about himself
as the Red Viper before this. #17 - More
Slates.
So this says from "Episode 5". In the next
slide you can actually see Cersei in black.
So we can probably adjust our timelines
just a little bit more.
I hope you're getting excited because it seems like big events are getting pushed
forward and forward and foward in the season!
#18 Rory McCann can actually starts all the
Joffrey Roast clips that the actors filmed
for that promotional stunt HBO did
earlier this year.
It was Maisie Williams and a few the
other actors making fun of Joffrey.
#19 - This is a much better shot the Royal
Wedding Feast.
#20 - The scene that they talk about the
takes up half the episode is most likely
the banquet
and the wedding combined. Look at all
those extras.
It's the biggest scene that they've
filmed since the Season 1 Premiere.
#21 - The actors talk about how amazing the
sets are.
The art designer Deborah Riley got a new
featurette that HBO did earlier
this year,
and the Art Designer Gemma Jackson from Season 3 won an
Art Directors Guild Award for their work
during that Season. They have some the
the best sets of
any show on television right now.  #22 - The
evolution of the Dragons.
This is one thing that I'm MOST excited
about in Season 4.
David Benioff talks about the challenges
that come with controlling the Dragons
once they become really big.
#23 - This is a good shot of the library of
the Night's Watch.
Or as close a thing as they have to it.
There are actually texts in there that
predate the creation of the wall.
I always thought that everything they
needed to win against the White Walkers
were in those books.
But because Sam is the only one who reads
them, the chances of them
finding that critical information is
really slim.
#24 - I just love that Gwendoline Christie is
almost giggling her way through
explaining this
really violent think Brienne has to do to
defend herrself. What a lovable goofball :)
#25 - DB Weiss actually says something
really good here.
While the Red Wedding represented this
epic set piece for Season 3,
Season 4 has several scenes that are
on that scale.
#26 - This is a really good external shot of Mereen.
#27 - Jamie unveils Brienne's new armor. She's actually wearing it during
this interview.
And finally, #28 - Let's leave it on Drogon.
Look at how much bigger he's gotten. He's
the biggest to the 3 and it becomes
a huge issue in Season 4 for Dany...He
looks hungry,
better watch out! So this was a lot of fun
again, but there is one more thing that I
want to add. Maisie Williams said
the good guys are coming back, but that
was a bit misleading. The subtext is is
that EVERYONE gets dumped on this Season. The good guys AND the bad.
And technically no one is either
really good or really bad. It's all
shades of gray.
Unless you are Ramsay Snow. That guy's just plain evil!
Like I said I'll be doing that Q&A video on Wednesday so just right any
questions you want to include in that
in the comments.
Right now Click Here for that other
Season 4 Breakdown Video. Careful for
spoilers.
and Click Here for my Review of Walking
Dead Season 4 Episode 9.
It just came back and it is so awesome!
THANK YOU so much you guys, I'll see
tonight. High Fives!